I have big news tonight out of Capitol
Hill Senate Judiciary Committee Chairman
Lindsey Graham of South Carolina
demanding answers from the FBI on the
now what third infamous raid this case
Roger stones home in Tampa Florida why
did the FBI send what 27 agents armed
with rifles body armor to arrest stone
for lying to Congress he's not all chapo
the senator also wants to know if CNN
fake news was tipped off by the Muller
team to get their exclusive footage of
course of this raid oh they picked the
perfect day joining us now with reaction
to all this breaking news tonight
Senator Lindsey Graham wait you were in
New York good to see you what are you
doing thank you very much um I won't but
I don't think that was about abortion in
the Commonwealth of Virginia right you
once sponsored a bill that I agree with
well I have it right now how many
nations in the world allow abortion on
demand after 20 weeks which is the fifth
month seven seven nations in the entire
world allow abortion on demand after 20
weeks they're talking about abortion
during the actual birthing so my bill
says unless there's a life of the
mothers at stake result of rape or
incest you can't have abortion on demand
in the fifth month I think most of
Maritimes for months to decide most
Americans will be fine with that let me
go to this letter director right yeah
and I'll be honest I I kind of expected
and have expected more in a director ray
because under James Comey we now have
two criminal investigations ongoing the
general counsel and his deputy director
I think there should be far more we
hopefully will get to that you have said
you will get into this talk about what
should he do why are we doing this to
people for process crimes and why does
it ever happen to all the other liberals
like clapper Brennan mills Abidine all
these other people that have lied to
Congress why don't they get the pre-dawn
raid so let me tell you my job my job is
to provide oversight to the Department
of Justice as the Judiciary Chairman
love the FBI respect them sort of what
somebody needs to watch those who watch
us I'm going to tell you all I can about
the FISA warrant and
I used to unverified dossier paid for
about political party without any
verification of that Russian lies yeah
so how ironic I want to know why to
execute a search warrant with somebody
who had a lawyer the what best way to
get Roger stone is to tell him CNN wants
to talk to you you know he'll show up
however you want him to show up so the
bottom line is this seems to me over the
top and I don't know what the message
was being sent but I personally didn't
like it you know I've been a prosecutor
defense attorney it seemed to be sending
the wrong message that if you trial
smuggler or look what's going to happen
to you
Muller do your job but these tactics are
unacceptable given the level of threat
here I look at his team here's a Clinton
Foundation attorney only democratic
donors no Republican donors and the man
who was excoriated for withholding
exculpatory evidence for for innocent
people in jail overturn Fifth Circuit
tens of thousands of Enron employees and
run accounting lost their jobs lost I
know in the Supreme Court he's the lead
guy well if they're sending a message
I'm sending a message to them you're
you're accountable to the Congress and
we're gonna find out what you well they
better answer my letter okay our them I
would and we'll get to the bottom of
FISA somebody signed off on something
they didn't verify yeah and didn't
corroborate he just put it this way what
if the roles were reversed what if the
republican party hired a former british
agent to go to rush of to dig up dirt on
hillary clinton and hate it and
everything in the dossier was a bunch of
BS
do you think that might be front page
news everywhere all the time
you're the Grassley Graham memo infamous
memo said bulk of information that is
they committed a fraud on the court and
they never told the court which they
knew according to Bruce horse testimony
that they paid for all right I got to
get to him okay a lot of conservatives
looked at Donald Trump New York
businessman and don't donated a
Republicans and Democrats at one point
was actually pro-choice he he's pro-life
now he kept his promises on judges taxes
regulations energy now he's trying to
fight for the wall I'm telling
I told people that he's going to
governor's a conservative right some
doubted me I think I've been proven
right and I would say now I'm 99%
certain either the Defense Department
budget or emergency money is going to be
used and he's relentless and tenacious
and changing strategies not losing so to
everybody who's wondering how this movie
ends it ends this way we're going to
build a wall one way or the other I just
talked to the president 10 minutes
before I came over here so I know for a
fact it was in the green room so here's
a point we're trying to make the five
point seven billion dollars represents
ten locations according to the
Department of Homeland Security that a
barrier would make the most difference
it's a professionally designed plan if
you look at the ten locations on the
border where the professionals say we
need a barrier it adds up to 5.7 billion
every Democrat virtually is voted for
634 miles of fencing when you ask people
where the ten locations of the 634 miles
we need something up now they gave us
the location in the price tag is 5.7
billion the president's not doing
anything crazy what's crazy is that
they're fighting him after having voted
the way they did in the past just in the
Obama's a few years ago just a few and
the president - that's right at 12 for
18 everything that offered things
Democrats dreamed about so I thought so
let me just let me tell you what not
amnesty here's that here's the
conversation the president wants to work
with Democrats he doesn't the shutdown
is not the way to get a result he did it
because he had nobody to work with
Democrats are over playing their hand if
you want tea platform and doctor reforms
Oh get it get it but you won't get it
but you didn't - if he does it by
himself I'm worried I only have ten
seconds about your Republican colleagues
I'm worried too if you don't stand by
this president
every President Bush Obama and Trump
sent troops to the border what's unusual
about that nothing what's the difference
between sending a troop to secure the
border and build a barrier while they're
there what he has all the power in the
world to do this - my Republican
colleagues stand behind him exactly it's
good for the country and if you Darwin
trying
pay a price good to see you thank you
for stopping by appreciate